la victoria parece estar a la vista para
los manifestantes decir blanca pero dos
días después de haber forzado al
presidente a anunciar su dimisión siguen
en las calles y ocupando el palacio
presidencial la calma ha vuelto a
colombo pero hasta qué gotabaya
rajapaksa no se aparte como prometió el
miércoles la gente no se mueve
la gente no abandonará la residencia del
presidente ni la del primer ministro
hasta que los líderes limiten
oficialmente si no se van el miércoles
13 el pueblo a saltar a cualquier
edificio en el que se escondan
el martes los funcionarios de
inmigración de cine lanka dijeron que
habían impedido que el hermano de raya
pax a basil ex ministro de finanzas
saliera del país un día antes se informó
que el presidente fue escoltado hasta
una base aérea lo que suscitó las
especulaciones de que también intentaría
exiliarse ambos rajapaksa tienen la
nacionalidad estadounidense el
presidente ha prometido dimitir para dar
paso a un gobierno de unidad se espera
que la principal oposición designe al
líder saljic premadasa hijo del
presidente asesinado rana cine premadasa
como su candidato a la jefatura del
estado
el mandato popular del presidente del
primer ministro y del gobierno ha
terminado única tudela
porque se han unido y han destruido
nuestra hermosa patria nosotros en la
oposición
estamos dispuestos a liderar a
estabilizar el país a reconstruir la
economía del país
el parlamento de sri lanka elegirá un
nuevo presidente el 20 de julio